ça y est ça y est à l'aller on prend la
faute
c'est prêt
mathieu qui viennent du même panier et
l'un d'eux gentil attentionné patients
mal alors que l'autre juste
voie juste un oeuf
les jumeaux est un endroit où passer
leur été qu'il fasse partie d'une
communauté personnellement j'ai pas très
envie de faire partie d'une communauté
alain maintenant je suis sérieux j'ai dû
organiser une collecte de fonds avec eux
ni les termes eva blanc voulait-elle
viens tu me suis retenu pour pas leur
pays
vous avez la vallée pour vous tout seul
je devrais sans doute me présenter non
ciman drake
ces magiciens
[Musique]
je vais disparaître certaines choses
plus tard comme vous repensez à cette
occasion
vous vous direz que c'était à ce moment
précis que vous auriez dû tenter quelque
chose
nous conduisait vous
chez nous
mon mari n'est pas c'est un indice ism
alors dis-moi ce que tu veux que je dise
je veux tu parle seulement de toi
c'est du passé alors laissons tout ça
dans le passé
tu ferais mieux de me tuer en vitesse
parce que sinon c'est moi qui vais te
tuer comment
[Musique]
on sait jamais jamais jamais ce que la
journée de réserve